[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima and i'm
denny direct oh thank you for joining us
live here for our official oscars
preview ahead of Sunday's big show oh
it's gonna be a big show everybody of
course we are winding down an
unforgettable award season is a long one
the Oscars are feeling very late this
year but some of the important moments
from the times up movement and so much
more it's the 90th Oscars so you guys we
are gonna be talking about who we think
will win who should win Oscars swag and
so much more right now we want to know
what you think let us know your
predictions in the comment section will
get them right here and talk about it
and please let us know we need you guys
to comment because the Best Picture race
alone is so hard to predict this year I
think more so than any year before
there's usually a clear front-runner but
so many of these films have gotten so
much love across the award season last
year you had moonlight versus Long
Island this one you got all of them
seriously we got you know you have some
shape of water and three billboards
which have been critical darlings all
awards season long then you have some
box office successes in Dunkirk you know
and get out of course who we're
predicting will take the trophy that
night is shape of water it's leading the
pack with 13 nominations the most of any
film it's got three nominations for its
actors and of course its director
Guillermo del Toro I just feel it has
like a lot of momentum going into the
Oscars ahead of Sunday yes well of
course last year we had that big may I
have the envelope please moment we have
some new reporting on what might happen
on Sunday night that's gonna be a little
nod to that so you guys should check it
out in et online.com because we gotta
have some info for you that's right yeah
it feels wide open doesn't it the thing
is we think who will win shape of water
we think who should win man I wish get
out could take this one home I'm like
I'm hoping I'm hoping you know it's it's
uh it's got its got some chances though
it really really does it's the film
everybody's talking about it really
stepped up it's Oscar campaign and this
like last haul you know what I mean
totally billboards are all over Los
Angeles like it's hard to ignore it's a
film people are still talking about and
it came out a while ago well it was hard
for them was that it came out so long
ago so it really had to give it a new
award season push and of course what the
Oscar struggles with is the fact like
you just said Bill
courts are up around Los Angeles because
that's where the Oscars voters are guys
we know it they're right here in this
town but we also want to make sure that
the Oscars are not isolating the viewers
the audience and get out with such a
huge box-office hit so it's been an
issue for the Ords for the past couple
years these indie darlings getting the
wins more so than those box-office
movies and also get out really is so
relevant to today you know to me and I
feel like if it's in a very big message
if the Academy chose get out and also
for genre Silence of the Lambs is the
only horror film that has ever won Best
Picture I think it's time for get out
and this is the horror film to do it
don't you think yes but also I got to
say what get out had working against it
all Awards season long as people didn't
know what to call this movie they're
like is it a horror is it a little bit
comedic what is it and so it got itself
in a tough situation there but let's
move on socially relevant and so with
three billboards and I see max is saying
billboard will win he's very confident
about that
yes well other nominees that we have you
guys I mean darkest hour I don't see
that one winning it's definitely gotten
acting recognition but not so much as a
you know a movie Best Picture winner
type of moment the post Tom Hanks Meryl
Streep Steven Spielberg well there you
go phantom thread
Daniel day-lewis his last movie and
Everts gotten amazing reviews for both
the movie itself and his performance but
it's not really a movie that a ton of
people have gone out and seen and it
came out really late exactly and did
score a bunch of nomination so the
Academy recognized it but I think that's
their win is that they got recognized
with this it's is they're invited to the
party how does the shape of water should
win such a beautiful film people have
talked so much about how not only was it
a good movie and great acting but just a
gorgeous movie so it does have all those
elements going for sure
you mentioned darkest hour which leads
us to our next category lead actor
because this man has swept the lead
actor category all Awards season long
and I'm talking about Gary Oldman in
darkest hours like morning folks but ya
know he has swept all the awards all
season long the BAFTA Golden Globes SAG
Awards and also he is one of those
people who has been nominated before but
has never won I feel like this is his
his Oscar yeah you get those kind of
career moments and Oscars and what's
really interesting here is that who we
kind of wish should win is somebody
who's just
hangout Timothy sha'lame for call me by
your names he has had one of those
seasons where first of all everybody
says his acting in this movie is amazing
I know you loved it loved it loved it
and second of all he's just had such a
fun award season to watch because he's
in his early 20s this is all so new to
him he's so excited I've loved
interviewing him he's just like yeah I
mean I met Meryl Streep it was awesome
he's he's so much fun to watch he's also
the youngest nominee and I just feel
like it would be so awesome to see that
you know that age he's 21 22 be awarded
on the stage and just to hear what he
has to say would be awesome and plus I
mean stellar stellar work and called me
by your name so I had we have to give
him a shout-out I know I do wish he
would win but I don't think he will
because like you said people are
probably looking at him also in thinking
career-wise he's an amazing actor he's
gonna have more opportunities after this
so sometimes that almost hurts younger
actor Jerry had the flashy role you know
was it was it was bigger the
transformation exactly a full
transformation so obviously it's gonna
go to that Hazim agrees best athlete and
best movie shape of water okay you guys
we are on the same page about this okay
but I agree also like you just said I
would love to see an unfiltered Oscar
speech you know because if somebody like
Timothy Xiaomei got up there he's
younger he just say stuff you know what
that is a perfect perfect segue to lead
actress because Frances McDorman has
also been sweeping all those words he's
in long and she has also been delivering
some amazing and very memorable award
species so you say you want to
unfiltered Oscar speech we might get it
in the shape of Frances McDormand see
what I did there I see you there and
Francis Francis doesn't care because she
gets up there she says what she wants to
say you have kind of an endearing
nervousness along with her like I don't
care I'm saying whatever I'm gonna say
because she just really doesn't plan it
out and that's why some of her speeches
after she's won in different awards
shows the season for three billboards
have been so awesome to watch and I do
think that she is the front-runner here
she's gotten other awards season love
and and the one to be someone else who
has gotten a lot of attention this year
is Saoirse Ronan
so we're thinking she could be a
possible Dark Horse here too but that
being said like we were mentioning in
Frances McDorman though she has got a
lot of love from the Academy and also in
her performance in three billboards I
felt was like really layered you kind of
got all different sides of her act
it'd be kind of hard to ignore that yeah
ladybird has really put Saoirse on
another level this season rightfully so
and I'm glad that you just said her name
because again it's it's Saoirse
there's our sugar chef which by the way
she's also a young in and this is her
third Oscar nomination I mean okay I can
barely pay my rent oh my god Jimmy I
love this he says Shalem a is the next
DiCaprio amen I greet that do you agree
with that yeah he's already good luck in
a bunch of roles and some high-profile
roles one with Netflix like we're gonna
see a lot of Timmy he's gonna be walking
on that stage one day hopefully not as
long as it took for Leo to get his Oscar
but Timothy looking up yeah I'm not no
you guys by the way
et one thing I just love about working
here is we've been interviewing these
people since the beginnings of their
careers so we have some great content up
at et online.com with all of our Oscars
coverage check all that out we're really
kind of trying to get you guys the long
interviews from all these different
nominees so you really get in depth on
what they're into so another three
billboards moment she was moving to
supporting actor absolutely I think who
will and should win is Sam Rockwell for
three billboards outside Edmond Missouri
he definitely had the flashy role and
also his character in that film as ugly
as he was really did have a character
arc not like the jerk his character is
deserty but he was a bad bad person in
this film but he also had a really
really big character arc and so you got
to see him kind of like what you'd like
to see that evolve in his performance I
mean again he's been sweeping all the
awards to Willem Dafoe has been getting
some Critics Awards here in there but I
think Sam is the one to beat he's
definitely the one to beat and that's
such a good point that you just mean
because sometimes those more subtle
performances do get passed over for that
big flashy role that was full of grit
and understandably so on a certain level
but Sam Rockwell he's also somebody
who's been in the industry for a while
and I think a lot of people really love
him are friends with him and excited to
see him have a moment he has he's had a
long career but also his first Oscar
nomination so I feel like you know
there's also that momentum to he's
hungry he's excited
he's like Timothy except he's been
around for a long time you know what I
mean so it'll be fun to watch him win I
would have just loved to be on the set
of that movie hanging out with Francis
McDormand Woody Harrelson Sam Rockwell
yes please okay so Supporting Actress
another one that we feel is pretty
locked in this year you guys who should
win
Janny for I Tanya and who probably will
win allison janney for at Sonya I can't
think of off the top of my head right
now an awards show that she hasn't won
for it why not yet the Oscars well I'm
sure it has to happen for this movie I
mean BAFTAs Golden Globes she is just
killing it for this role and again I
think rightfully so the person who wrote
this movie actually was a friend of hers
and wrote this part just with Alison in
mind so it was so perfect for her and I
think it's been a really emotional
awards season for her she told me that
she's been friends with that
screenwriter for such a long time and
that she was just so happy to finally
get the chance to work with him and that
it's all coming to fruition in this
movie that they really turned and burned
on and made so quickly and now it's
become this award season powerhouse and
we're also talking about someone who
like Sam Rockwell has been in the
industry for so long playing so MIT
she's a character actress right and
she's also the queen of the Emmys she's
racked up like seven or eight and the
awards and has never been invited to the
Oscars until this performance and I feel
like this is her time like this is gonna
be so fun to watch let's talk about the
fact that she is on you know the hit
show mom right now and then over hon
over in the Oscar nominations you know
it's been fun to to see in this category
I'm of course Laurie Metcalf also
nominated for Lady Bird very similar
stories there in the two of them because
Laurie was a TV person on Roseanne she
done some theater as she told me she'd
really not done many movies and then all
of a sudden she's playing this amazing
mom character in Lady Bird and getting
an Oscar nomination for it it's a cool
story for what they definitely parallels
cuz they also both play problematic
mothers you know people they're they're
not the best moms you know they're not
they're not the best moms but Allison if
you compare the two performances had the
more grittier one it was a pretty bad
three that mom and a spot-on impression
that was pretty good oh my gosh by the
way you guys yeah please keep your
comments coming in after says Sam
Rockwell we'll take it min says Allison
rocks Natasha says Octavia please
Octavia Spencer nominated in the shape
of water
she made some history this year she is
the first African American woman to be
nominated three times for an Oscar in
the same category yes Queen yes yes yes
you amaze yourself so as we said you
guys it's so hard to predict who's gonna
win Best Picture
but one thing we can't tell you is like
they're not gonna let that flub happen a
second time although I will make the
argument
but when that happened last year that
mix-up it gave us some kind of life I we
were speechless in the office last year
me it's so much more fun interesting yes
and it's something Jimmy agrees with to
host Jimmy Kimmel he told et that the
worst thing about the Oscars can be as
boring but does he have PTSD et's Kevin
Frazier actually talked to the man
himself to find out is there any PTSD no
no no in fact it went great except for
the thing at the end which you know turn
out to be a something that was
interesting to people you know and I
guess the the worst thing the Oscars can
be is boring I think right what will be
different from last year it seems like
every year there are serious things
happening this year it seems like there
are nine of them all happening at once
so that's something that I think has to
be handled has to be balanced
I think there's anybody who could find
that balance is Jimmy Kimmel honest show
he yes platform for such poignant and
important topics you know what I mean
and he's funny so I'm excited to see
that but ya know envelope mix-up this
year I don't think I love how he
referred to it is the thing at the ends
right that thing that happened at the
end you know that massive mix-up that
went down in Oscars history hotcake can
I say something I feel like we need
another best pitcher picks up just to
liven it up a little bit I have to say I
think the Oscars has the biggest
challenge ahead of them because they're
the last awards show of the season and
it's been so awesome to see times up in
the me to movement be part of the sort
of season but now at this point you know
the Golden Globes started things out
everybody's wearing all black so
powerful such an amazing carpet to be on
how does the Oscars keep that momentum
going keep it important it's a lot of
questions to answer and we're gonna talk
about that but by the way real quick let
me get into you guys
they have taken additional precautions
to make sure that envelope mix-up won't
happen again
no cell phones are being allowed back
there more people are on hand to keep an
eye on things because it was just that
one gonna be different colors color
coordinate color code you know it's red
don't take it take the blue pill don't
know the reference guys these are our
lives but let's talk a little bit about
me too and time is up and how it will be
addressed in the show so like we said
it's not
gonna be a situation where everybody's
wearing black on the carpet as they did
for the Globes we're not gonna see that
sweeping everybody in the same color
moment however people do want to make
sure that it's still part of the
conversation so what we know is that it
will somehow be addressed on stage I
know you have a little bit of detail on
how we think oh yes so some of the times
up managers actually invited select
press today for a meeting to tell them
how they're gonna dress in the Oscars
basically as you mentioned there's no
all black dress code but ava duvernay
did say that they have been in talks
with show producers to carve out a
moment during the telecast to address
time's up and what's going on in there
and their whole initiative but ya know
all black yeah which kind of makes sense
though because you know obviously the
the blackout happened at the Golden
Globes which was one of the first major
award shows of the year and it was the
official launch of the times up movement
so they kind of had to make a big
statement now I think they're gonna keep
a lower profile at the Oscars it's been
interesting to see how it's continued
through award season we've been watching
everybody weren't all black at this one
no Nicole Kidman's in hot pink okay okay
but the BAFTAs just acknowledged it
again so it's still part of the
conversation which is so important sue
says is it true that Faye Dunaway and
Warren Beatty are going to present best
picture again sue I'm gonna advise you
to head over to ET online on that we
want to make sure you guys check it out
and get the full story so head over to
our website here's the thing the Oscars
are serious but they're fun too they're
really fun yeah I know what I've always
wanted to know what's in gift bags and
guess what guys we know we know this
unofficial Oscars gift bag you want to
hit them with yes so guys there are only
26 of these again they're unofficial but
they are swag bags to the max each is
worth wait for it $100,000 there will be
one for each nominee in the five major
categories and you know when Jimmy
Kimmel's working hard so he gets to take
one home to the most expensive item you
guys wait for this is a 12 night
adventure in Tanzania for two people
valued at $40,000 how can I get one two
people right here okay yes thank you
oh my nominated for an Oscar I gotta get
over to an acting class you know what we
got time there are twenty-four hundred
bottles of wine
involved in all this and 1500 bottles of
champagne will be flowing you guys so we
know that the Oscars are still gonna be
a good time it's so awesome and ETS
always right there on the red carpet
when you see you know somebody like
celebrity chef Wolfgang Puck bring out
all that food they're gonna be eating
it's rich we have a look of the food
menu actually from Wolfgang you guys
this is the feast
everyone will be snacking on courtesy of
Wolfgang Puck includes $10,000 worth of
caviar thirty-six thousand dollars worth
of truffles and get this beef flown in
from Japan as well I mean it's the
Academy Awards I guess oh there it is I
think that's the beef as Lauren
mentioned the the wine and champagne
will be flowing twenty-four hundred
bottles of champagne you need it of wine
I should say imagine this dress cheers
Cheers Oscar's well you guys the thing
is imagine the stress that these
celebrities are under when they're in
the audience at the Oscars all season
long has been building up to this moment
I mean they've got to make sure they
look perfect they've been eating right
they've been campaigning
it's they've been doing interviews it's
been a lot and they also get to the
point where you know we're out there
doing the interviews and we're thinking
how can we get some news here what do we
want to ask them and they're thinking
how can I keep myself interesting it's a
lot of pressure for celebrities I think
can you also imagine winning the thing
he's got to go up there in front of the
world and deliver a speech I remember
Jennifer Lawrence said after she won
backstage the first thing she did was
take a shot she took a shot so I get it
you know she probably was she'd had one
right before she went out well then
maybe she wouldn't have fallen up the
stairs to get the Oscar but you know
these are our favorite moments well
folks we'll see who falls up the stairs
when the 90th Academy Awards air live
coast-to-coast
on Sunday March 4th at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific on ABC's yes and of course
you guys ET is going to be on the red
carpet and not only on the red carpet
with our own Kevin Frazier and Nancy
O'Dell we will also be at all the
parties the Vanity Fair Oscar party the
Governor's Ball with Cameron Mathison
and Carly steel in a shell Turner we're
just gonna bring you guys all the behind
the scenes moments that you aren't gonna
see on TV so make sure that you tune in
to e team Monday night to check those
out and I'll also be on the carpet so
please follow along with me if you can
and Donnie and I are gonna be talkin
Oscar
we are bunkering down join us right
after the Oscars airs we're gonna break
down the most talked about moments the
best speeches live here on Facebook
Twitter YouTube you know where to find
us
guys thanks so much for watching and of
course head over to ET online.com and
watch ET tonight for the very latest on
what's going to go down on Sunday that's
right cheers guys bye
[Music]